MICHAL SEGALOV: Hi.
Welcome to the second
episode of "Women
Techmakers" in Israel.
"Women Techmakers" is a series
of videos which brings more
visibility to successful women
entrepreneurs around the world.
It started in the United States,
and we're glad to host
the first series of episodes
outside the United States.
I'm Michal Segalov.
I'm a software engineer
at Google.
Currently, I work in technical
infrastructure.
So my team designs software
that's internally used by
other teams in Google.
Prior to that, I worked
on YouTube.
And prior to that, on
search quality.
We have with us Dana.
DANA GABEL: Hi, my
name is Dana.
I'm also a software engineer
with Google.
I've been with Google
over five years.
Currently, I'm working on Google
Knowledge and Identity.
Previously, I worked on the
AdWords's API and different
targeting methods for ads at
Google, and worked on social
discovery on G+.
And I also have three kids.
MICHAL SEGALOV: And today we're
hosting Yael Karov, CEO
and founder of Ginger
Software.
So Yael, can you please
introduce yourself?
YAEL KAROV: Hi.
I'm Yael Karov.
I'm the founder and CEO
of Ginger Software.
I founded Ginger
five years ago.
And before founding Ginger, I
worked in high tech for 15
years, in roles of VP R&D and
CTO in three companies.
And before that, I had my MSc
from the Weizmann Institute of
Science in mathematics
and computer science.
I married, and I have
three kids.
MICHAL SEGALOV: So Yael, you had
a very successful career,
and you're now working
as the CEO of Ginger.
Can you please tell us a little
bit about Ginger and
what it does, how the
idea came about?
YAEL KAROV: Gladly.
So I founded Ginger
with the idea--
Actually, I knew, myself, when I
wasn't sure about how to use
English, just trying in Google,
actually, searching
for various alternatives.
For example, whether I should
say, in Monday or on Monday?
What is most popular?
And then I thought, OK, I can do
it statistically using the
same method of checking what is
most popular statistically
on the web using it in order
to correct the English of
other people.
So this would be a useful tool
for everyone as you try to
correct your English.
And I realized that it is going
to be good not only for
correcting people's English
but also for correcting
machine text, like a machine
translation and speech
recognition, which
also produced
incorrect text many times.
So I looked at the algorithms
of speech recognition and
machine translations, and I
realized, with a proof of
concept, that there was another
statistical model that
can correct also the
machine text.
So I started just by placing a
patent on this specific idea
and domains.
And then my husband, who
is also a very strong
technologist [INAUDIBLE], he
started developing the proof
of concept.
And we raised money based
on the proof of concept.
DANA GABEL: We want to ask you,
where do you think Ginger
fits in as an area of English
as a second language?
YAEL KAROV: So I would go at
least to cover the vast
majority of English as a second
language speakers that
already know the basic
vocabulary but are very far
from being native English
speakers.
So they can write and speak
English, but with a lot of
mistakes and the vocabulary
is not good enough.
And our goal is to help them
online in the writing, whether
they're writing in mobile or
any desktop application,
everywhere they write just to
correct their writing, to
learn the English profile,
understand personal culture.
Understand what is wrong with
their English, and then offer
them private lessons that are
tailored for them to improve
their English.
And it's not just grammar
and spelling.
It's to improve their vocabulary
and pronunciation,
to improve their overall
English.
So it's a complementary software
to English learning
schools or courses.
DANA GABEL: Yael, in your mind,
what is crucial for a
start-up to be successful?
YAEL KAROV: So I think it starts
with leading a team.
I think the team should work
very well together and should
have a very clear vision of the
goal of the company, and
they should complement
each other.
And the second thing,
I think, is the
strategy of the company.
I think when you start a
start-up with some goal in
mind, it's never what
you end with.
So I think it's to be
constantly aware to
opportunities and changes in
the world and feedback from
your users, your investors, and
the people you work with.
And to know which changes to
take, and to change your
original goals, because of all
this feedback and inputs
you're exposed to.
And which opportunities
and changes
and feedback to ignore.
And to keep your--
even though the people will tell
you that it's not going
to work or not to work in a
reasonable time, and so which
ones not to.
So I think the strategy
is critical.
And then last, of course,
is the execution.
Because you can have the best
ideas and strategy, but a lot
of things just succeed or fail
because of execution.
MICHAL SEGALOV: Do you have an
example of how Ginger changed
its strategy along the way?
YAEL KAROV: Yes.
Absolutely.
I must say that there are
many things I would
do differently today.
So first is which market you
are going to go for.
So our technology and products
fit consumers.
Every user can download our
product from our website.
And this requires online
marketing to get to consumers.
But it also fits the education
market, so just to schools,
for example.
And the corporate market,
because basically almost any
employee in any international
corporation needs it.
So in the beginning, we tried
to grow in parallel on all
these three markets, because
we thought, it's the same
product and it's just a matter
of doing marketing in parallel
in three different domains.
But eventually, we got to the
conclusion we should focus
only on the online market.
Because you sort of cheat
yourself when you think that
you can do all these market
segments without much extra
product to work and management
to work.
So this is one example
of a change.
And the second example is that
we started only with a focus
of English learning.
So we have that Proofreader
and the
English improvement software.
But we did not develop in the
beginning the other products
that are on natural language
understanding.
And in the last year, we started
developing for the
speech recognition
engine and the
personal assistant software.
DANA GABEL: This actually leads
to our next question.
What are some other technology
trends that
you are excited about?
YAEL KAROV: So I am personally
excited about anything that
helps computers understand
the human language.
And so what is most exciting
for me today is actually
personal assistant.
Because it's a change, I
believe, that in the next few
years we are going to see that
people speak with a mobile
phone in a natural language
command without televisions,
tablets, and computers.
And that it's going to change
the way people interact with
their computer.
And I find it most exciting,
because it's going to affect
basically almost everybody
in the world.
Also, the technology behind it
excites me, because in order
to understand the user or
to be able to make some
conversation with the
user, it's the
classical problem in AI.
And for me, I think it's one
of the most challenging and
interesting problems
to work on.
DANA GABEL: That's great.
What is the technological or
growth potential you see for
Ginger in your future?
MICHAL SEGALOV: Maybe
show us a demo, too.
YAEL KAROV: That
would be great.
I will.
So we are going in two
different avenues.
One is actually just going
our major product, the
Proofreader, into also
suggesting variations to the
sentence the user wrote.
So even if the user is a native
English speaker, if he
writes, I love you or I miss
you, it would be helpful for
him to get many other ways that
other people say it on
the web that means the
same but they say it
in different words.
So this is one problem
we are working on.
And it's also some goals of
our products to people who
speak English as a
first language.
And the second one is to use
our natural language
understanding technology for
speech recognition and
personal assistant that
understands the intent and
slots that the user
querying had.
DANA GABEL: So do you want
to show us a demo
now before we continue?
YAEL KAROV: Yeah, absolutely.
So I'll start by demonstrating
our
Proofreader for the desktop.
So it works in any office
application or
any browser and website.
So this is an example
writing in Gmail.
And then I'll show the mobile
interfaces we have and the
next version we are working on
that shows variations of the
different sentences.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
YAEL KAROV: The technology
grows, yes.
But it's actually in the aspect
of speech recognition
and personal assistant.
So I will now show how our
software can improve the
speech recognition QOC by
understanding the context of
the user query.
In this specific example, the
user wants to order take-away,
but it can be any kind of other
product that the user
would like to order.
And we understand the intent
of the user, what type of
product-- in this case, what
type of food the user wants,
in which price range, if he
indicated the restaurant or
not, his location, and so on.
And the second example is not
just a speech recognition
improvement but also
performing the
task for the user.
But really, the user can order
a product just in a single
sentence, in less than 30
seconds instead of spending 10
times by interacting with
the mobile application.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hi.
So today I'm going to
demonstrate the Ginger Express
application, which I'll
launch just now.
So this is a Start screen,
and it asks you
what you want to order.
I want to order a tuna salad
with Swiss cheese, please.
So as you can see,
we transcribe
the sentence correctly.
And when we look at the
results-- for example, there's
a chef salad here, a few
chef salads, actually.
And if you want to understand
why we selected those--
because as you can see, they
have both Swiss cheese and
tuna in their description.
Likewise for this one.
A chef salad with Swiss cheese
and tuna in them.
Let me try another order.
I want to order two hamburgers
and four French fries, please.
So first of all, the first
thing you'll see is that
actual order was placed
correctly.
Namely, we have two hamburgers
and four French fries here.
Two turkey burgers and four
French fries, two pizza
burgers and four French fries.
What you don't see and is a real
accomplishment is that
Ginger was actually able to
improve upon Google's speech
detects engine.
So as you can see, the original
results received by
Google were--
I want to order to, T-O,
hamburgers and for, F-O-R,
French fries.
And Ginger was able to decode
these results and return the
correct ones.
Namely, T-W-O, two hamburgers
and four, F-O-U-R, French
fries, receiving the correct
results, which is quite nice.
Now, let me conclude with
one final example.
I want to order a banana
cheesecake, please.
So again, we got the right
transcription,
as you can see here.
Notice that the first result
is one banana.
The question is why
we chose it.
Well, it's in the section
of the cheesecakes.
So we ordered a banana
cheesecake, and we identified
the dish not by its actual name
but by its name together
with the section in
which it appears.
Likewise, before, we did that
with the dish name and its
description.
So I hope you've enjoyed this
demonstration today.
Thank you.
So today we'll be showcasing
and demonstrating Ginger's
capabilities in augmenting and
improving speech-to-text
capabilities in a
post-processing method.
Which relies on taking the
results received from a
standard speech or text engine
such as Google or Nuance, and
breaking it down into the
phonetic representation, and
regenerating candidates
in order to
yield the correct response.
I want a ham sandwich.
Now, here you see how Ginger was
able to not only correct
but actually generate
the correct answer
and choose it correctly.
So Google saw, I want
to Huntington Beach.
And Ginger was able to
phonetically map that onto the
correct answer and augment
the results with,
I want a ham sandwich.
I want to order pasta
bolognese.
Note that, as you can see here,
Google got, I want to
order possible Inez.
And Ginger Express was able to
correct this using our decoder
and phonetic similarity to the
correct pasta bolognese.
I want to order two hamburgers,
please.
So here you see the Ginger
Express was able to identify
the correct, I want to order
two hamburgers, please.
Whereas Google yielded the
following result--
I want to order two hamburg--
U-R-S, please.
So Ginger Express was able to
identify the correct essential
phonemes and regenerate the
correct answer, two
hamburgers.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DANA GABEL: Yael, you are
leading a lot of efforts in
the company you're running.
How do you divide your efforts
between pushing near-term
goals and planning
strategically?
YAEL KAROV: So it starts by
building the management team
in a way that matches
these goals.
So we have a different VP R&D
for the short-term goals,
which are releasing
new versions to
the existing products.
And we have a VP of NLP
Platform, Micha, who is in
charge of working on the
strategic projects for the
future of Ginger.
And this division, with its
different departments and
different software engineers,
it's very helpful, and it also
helps me to divide my
time between these
two different tasks.
DANA GABEL: If you had 20 more
skilled engineers joining
Ginger tomorrow, what would
you want them to focus on?
YAEL KAROV: First, I
would be so happy.
So I would divide them between
two different goals.
The first one is that our new
version of suggesting
variations to your sentences
and that helps you say
something in a different way
than the way you are used to.
So I would really
like to release
it as soon as possible.
It's one of the most
exciting, I think,
products in our company.
And because there's no
other product that
is similar to this.
And the second goal I would
devote to is speech
recognition improvement and
the personal assistant,
because the personal assistant
project is huge.
You can do--
DANA GABEL: You could staff it
with as many engineers--
YAEL KAROV: 200 engineers.
Still I was able to do with
it two [INAUDIBLE].
DANA GABEL: OK.
That's great.
What are the major partnerships
Ginger currently
has, or you would
like it to have?
YAEL KAROV: Two types
of partnerships.
The first one is to integrate
Ginger into different
platforms with user rights.
So we offer an SDK for websites,
like any web mail or
social network, anywhere people
write [INAUDIBLE].
Just in a single minute of
downloading our product for a
website, they can offer
the users text
correction for free.
And the second platform
is mobile.
So we offer mobile manufacturers
or mobile
application developers, again,
to use our SDK and offer the
users a text correction.
The second type of partner are
English-learning players.
So any network of
English-learning school for
adults, for example, can
distribute to the
students our software.
And it will also help them to
teach their students in a
better way, because the teachers
will be able to see
the level of English students
have and what are the most
frequent problems
of each student.
So it will help them
to personalize
their learning courses.
DANA GABEL: It looks like you
feel strongly about making a
difference.
So Ginger recently changed its
business model to the premium,
premium model.
So how is it going to
make money now?
YAEL KAROV: So currently, we are
offering our Proofreader
for free, but soon we are going
to start monetizing by
offering our users to use
our premium product.
And the difference between the
premium and the free product,
first, is that you
get an unlimited
usage of the software.
With the Proofreader, it's
limited to a certain number of
corrections you accept
per month.
Also suggesting them the
sentence variations is going
to be limited in the same way,
so you can, for example, get
50 variations of sentences
for free per month.
But then if you use it
for more than that,
then you need to pay.
And the second differentiator
is the functionality.
So in the premium product, we
also help people improve their
English based on their frequent
mistakes, and not
just get online help.
So we help them improve their
grammar, their vocabulary, and
pronunciation.
MICHAL SEGALOV: I have one more
question about Ginger.
So in a way, your main client
base is not English speakers
as a first language, so I'm
assuming your main market is
not the United States.
But then some of your products,
like the enhancement
or the How Do You Say? feature
is targeted towards--
DANA GABEL: Personal
assistants.
MICHAL SEGALOV: Is that the
personal assistant ones are
targeted toward native
English speakers.
So how do you see
the differences
between these markets?
YAEL KAROV: So first what we
realized is that actually
countries which are
English-speaking countries
actually always have the
immigrant population.
And for example, in the United
States, it's 20% of the people
and then also in the UK--
and then these people actually
would like to improve their
English even more so than
people who live in other
countries, because they need
it for daily usage.
So currently, we distribute it
internationally, also in
English-speaking countries.
We do online marketing.
Then Ginger is available
to anyone from any
place in the world.
It's not that we do specific
biz dev efforts in specific
countries at the moment.
And so anyone that we search
for [INAUDIBLE]
it means that he has the need
regardless of the location.
I don't know if that answers
your question.
MICHAL SEGALOV: Yeah.
No, I know what you mean.
DANA GABEL: It's interesting
the marketing to
English-speaking countries
because of all the immigrants.
YAEL KAROV: And actually, we
realized that also people who
are native English speakers use
our product, because, for
example, in mobile, everyone
has mistakes.
If you type really quickly,
you have mistakes.
And there's no other tool in
mobile that can correct your
mistakes automatically and
use context for that.
MICHAL SEGALOV: Oh, that's a
really good use of this.
I should get that.
DANA GABEL: Definitely
for mobile.
MICHAL SEGALOV: So throughout
your career, it seems that you
work in very diverse
topics, right?
You started with NLP, and then
you switched over to
bioinformatics, and now
you're back here.
So how do you do these shifts?
Or what similarities
do you see?
YAEL KAROV: So there's a very
strong similarity, because all
the problems I work on were some
research problems that
require the machine learning
and statistical models to
solve them.
And actually, working on
genomics was very similar,
because DNA is also
a language.
And also, it uses statistical
models to learn the language.
Actually, there is a very high
similarity in the different
problems I was working on.
Of course, the difference is in
the product management and
marketing, which I was also
involved in, was dramatically
different, because the genomics
product I worked on
was diagnostic chips for cancer
based on the new genes
that we found in Rosetta
Genomics.
And then its product delivery is
completely different than a
consumer product with
online marketing.
So this is a dramatic
difference.
And I much prefer the consumer
products and online marketing.
MICHAL SEGALOV: Another big
change that you made is the
move from being CTO and VP R&D
in companies that you worked
in before to be the
founder and CEO.
So what made you
do this change?
How do you capture
these two roles?
What are your personal
preferences?
YAEL KAROV: So this is
a good question.
I actually, after holding this
job as a VP R&D and CTO job in
three different companies,
five years
each, I just gave birth.
So I went to a birth vacation,
and I had some time to think
about my career.
And I felt like I can't go again
to the same type of job
that I did for 15 years.
And that what makes a company
succeed eventually is not just
the technology but mainly, also,
the strategy and the
product management
and marketing.
And so I really wanted to
do it myself this time.
And it doesn't mean, of course,
that I don't do mistakes.
I absolutely do.
But at least I can learn from
them and make the changes, I
hope, quickly.
So it was a wish to lead the
strategy of my own company to
maximize as a success
[INAUDIBLE].
And I think the real question
is, why didn't I do it before?
Because it took me quite a
time until I got to it.
MICHAL SEGALOV: So what do you
feel prepared you the most in
the previous roles that you did
to your current as CEO?
YAEL KAROV: I think it was a
great preparation, because
first, it's management.
Regardless of the domain,
if it's technology,
just managing people.
So I did manage a
lot of people.
It was up to 50 or 70
people each time.
But still, it really
was extremely
helpful to the CEO role.
And the second thing is, of
course, just the technology
itself, just being able
to be the chief
scientist of the company.
Or to work extremely well with
the R&D manager and the CTO,
it's because of my background as
a CTO and VP R&D. So it was
very helpful.
MICHAL SEGALOV: Did you always
know you wanted to found your
own company?
Or did this come as a
realization some time in life?
YAEL KAROV: I think maybe if
I came from a different
background, I would
know it earlier.
But for me, I certainly had
no idea I wanted to be an
entrepreneur until
I became one.
And the reason, I think, it's
because I grew up in
[INAUDIBLE], which is in an
extremely religious place
where usually women do
not have a career.
And even if they have, they're
really tied to give their
focus only to their family.
And it was always very clear to
me that the family, for me,
is the top priority and
that I have kids or
that I will have kids.
And so I thought it would be
very difficult to combine
family with life, to be a good
mother with being an
entrepreneur.
It takes all your time.
And that was a mistake.
[? lets just ?]
So I hope that other women will,
I guess, learn from my
experience.
It doesn't have to be so.
You can be a very good mother
including being enough time
with your kids, and still run a
company and really devote to
it all the time.
[INAUDIBLE]
I think you can really
combine it very well.
And it was a mistake I had in my
perception for many years.
MICHAL SEGALOV: Can you tell us
how you got started as an
entrepreneur?
What were the first attempts at
entrepreneurship that you
took and how you started?
YAEL KAROV: So actually,
all along, I had
many ideas for companies.
And again, I just didn't do
it, not because I thought
maybe not succeed, but because
I thought it would
not work with kids.
And when I had this idea of
Ginger, of just the natural
language understanding using
the web, I was so
excited about it.
And I felt I can really do it
in relatively a short time
that I decided that this
time I will do it.
And my husband also was
extremely helpful in that,
because he developed the first
version of the product.
We decided together that he will
back me and really take a
significant role, not just like
50/50 partners but even
more at home.
So it was actually a
mutual decision.
MICHAL SEGALOV: So what
motivates you?
What are the things you are
most passionate about?
YAEL KAROV: Actually, what
motivates me is usually having
a very-- it's not that I told
myself, wow, I must be an
entrepreneur or I must
get to an exit.
It's absolutely not that.
It's the creation
process itself.
It's having a goal that I really
believe in, having an
idea for a product that can be
useful for many people and can
be helpful not just
to generate money
but really help people.
Having a belief that I have an
idea on how to do it that is
different from the existing
way it's done.
I can only work on something
that really, really excites me
and I really love.
I've never worked on anything
that bored me.
So I think that's a motive.
MICHAL SEGALOV: So another thing
that I must ask-- there
aren't a lot of women
entrepreneurs.
You must realize that
looking around you.
What do you think the reasons
are for that?
YAEL KAROV: So that's right,
unfortunately.
I think the reason is mainly
because many women decide they
want a family and a career
balance that would be broken
if they start their
own company.
They see how hard entrepreneurs
work, and this is true.
You really must work
extremely hard.
And I think many women are
afraid that it's going to
wound family life or
their motherhood.
And I can really understand
this concern.
But I really think that it
is possible to do the
two things at once.
It's difficult.
It's not easy, but I think
it's possible to do it.
MICHAL SEGALOV: So what
do you think are the
most important things?
You seem to have a great partner
by what you say.
YAEL KAROV: Yeah, I do.
Absolutely.
I feel extremely lucky
and thankful
to have now my husband.
I think it would be impossible
to do the balance very well
without him.
What do I think is important in
order to keep this balance?
I think first thing
is to build the
infrastructures to your life.
So that means, first, at work,
you need to have a strong
management that can work and
proceed also without you.
And at home, you need to build
the things that will be able
to run without you.
Except, of course, with time
with your husband or your
kids, that is an
emotional time.
But any practical, I think,
task in life, I think it's
possible to organize your life
such that you reduce your
practical stuff and just save
yourself all these hours of
practical things.
And I feel, also, I have a very
good support system when
unexpected things come up.
So I think my mother, my
husband's mother, our
babysitters group-- we have
maybe eight of them.
It's a whole support system.
DANA GABEL: You could
make another company
in parallel, no?
YAEL KAROV: Absolutely.
And I think it's helpful,
actually, to learn from how to
manage a high-tech company to
how to manage your private
life with people that are
responsible in different
aspects of your life.
DANA GABEL: Which
one is easier?
YAEL KAROV: Which
Actually, I imagine home
is much easier.
DANA GABEL: OK.
[INAUDIBLE].
MICHAL SEGALOV: Are you
super organized?
How do you do that?
YAEL KAROV: It's a tricky
question, because I think I'm
super organized on
infrastructures and whatever
needs to be sold offline.
So I will look at any problem,
doesn't matter if it's a
private problem or if at work.
We think it through and think
how to make the infrastructure
so that things in the future
will work in an easier way.
But I'm a very intuitive
person that
improvises all the time.
And I'm late all the time.
And I'm making changes
all the time.
So I'm not super organized in
that sense, in the sense of--
Like I always lose my house
keys and wallet and so on.
It's not in this sense that are
super-organized people.
DANA GABEL: It's more in
building for the future--
YAEL KAROV: Yeah.
So it's more analytical.
Just treating every problem,
it doesn't matter which
problem, analytically.
So just looking at, how do
they do it in the past?
How other people do it?
What should I learn?
And just design the optimal
solution and execute it.
DANA GABEL: It's very similar
to what you have to do at
work, right?
Solve very hard problems.
It's almost the same.
YAEL KAROV: It's very
similar actually.
DANA GABEL: So you're becoming
a role model for women, in
Israel at least, probably
not just.
Did you have any role models
when you grew up?
YAEL KAROV: Thanks.
Firstly, I must say that I feel
I still need to do my big
success before I become
a role model.
But even before that, having
a role model--
the place I grew in and the time
I grew in, there was no
internet, there was
no TV for me.
I didn't even read newspapers,
so I didn't know about--
certainly not about any
women in high tech.
I didn't even know about
men in high tech
until after my twenties.
So I didn't have any
technological role models.
My role models were more Gandhi
and Mother Teresa,
those people who made a huge
social revolution, because
they were idealists.
So those certainly were
my role models.
MICHAL SEGALOV: So how did you
get excited about technology
if it was so unfamiliar?
YAEL KAROV: It started when I
was, I think, 15 or 16 years
old that I found some book of
the Open University by David
[INAUDIBLE].
And it was a completely
theoretical computer science
book that really excited me.
And then when I went to study
mathematics and computer
science, I got immediately
excited about AI, which is not
a very fashionable term today.
But AI algorithms.
It was a very clear and
immediate excitement for me.
So it was clear to me when I
finished studying that I would
look for a company that solved
hard problems with interesting
algorithms.
And that's what I did.
That's how I got to
Click Software,
and it started there.
MICHAL SEGALOV: So did
you deliberately
select a smaller company?
YAEL KAROV: Yes.
I totally didn't care about
terms, [INAUDIBLE]
anything like that or any
comfortable factor.
I only looked for a product or
for a company that develops a
product with the most
interesting algorithms for me.
I'm sorry.
I forgot what you asked
after that.
MICHAL SEGALOV: If
you deliberately
wanted to go to a smaller--
YAEL KAROV: Ah, yes.
And I absolutely felt that I
match a small company better
than a big company, because
I felt I would be able to
influence small.
And also, it's very difficult
for me to deal with
bureaucracy.
I looked for a small company.
MICHAL SEGALOV: And--
oh, sorry.
DANA GABEL: Did you ever
get really good advice?
And who gave it to you?
YAEL KAROV: So it wasn't
personal advice to me, but I
think the advice of Steve Jobs
to Stanford graduates was
probably the best speech
I ever heard.
And what he said is really
follow your heart.
Do only the things
you believe in.
And don't work with the goal for
10 years or 20 years from
now and manage your career
logically towards this goal.
But follow your heart at
every point you have.
Eventually, all points
will be connected.
When you look back, you will
see that everything you did
served the goal you
really wanted.
I really believe in that.
That's exactly what I did.
And the reason it's very helpful
for me is also because
it encourages people to
only do things that
they believe in.
And sometimes it's very
difficult, because you have
opinions of many people around
you that tell you different
things from your beliefs.
And I turn back to his speech
and his advice every time I'm
in a dilemma with whether to
follow my heart and beliefs or
the advice of other people.
So of course, in many cases,
it's very good to listen to
other people and to follow
their advice.
But then your heart changes,
and you already want to do
what you heard from them,
because they explain
themselves, and you change
what you want.
And that's easy, of course,
if you listen and learn.
But when consistently you feel
that even though you heard
everyone and really listened to
them, you still believe in
a different thing, I think
you should do it.
MICHAL SEGALOV: Is this how
you know to move on?
How do you know when it's
time to go and move
to a different company?
YAEL KAROV: Yeah.
It's absolutely forming on
intuition and the stomach when
I feel my passion is
not there anymore.
And it's difficult to make me
lose my passion, because I
stayed at each company I worked
in at least five years.
And I always went through a lot
of crisis modes and that
this is not a reason
for me to run away.
But when I feel that I'm not
completely in love with the
goal I'm working for, then
this will hopefully
[INAUDIBLE].
DANA GABEL: Do you want to
give advice to the young
people at the beginning
of their career,
especially young women?
YAEL KAROV: I think it's divided
to two, which is--
The first thing is
for everyone.
I think really follow
your heart.
Go to work not in the
environment you think that
practically works the best for
you or looking at your
benefits and so on.
Go to the place that excites
you the most.
Eventually, also, if this is the
case, you will be good at
what you are doing, and
everything will
work well for you.
And the second advice is
specifically for women.
I think that if you think that
you really want-- not everyone
wants to-- but if you really
want to do your own ideas and
to start a company, and you're
afraid that it will not work
with being new mothers-- and I
really want to tell women that
I think it is possible to be a
very good mother-- and also
with quantity.
It's the number of hours you
spend with your kid, not just
quality time--
and to be very devoted
to your company.
It's possible to combine it.
MICHAL SEGALOV: How do you
maintain your technical
credibility and technical
involvement while being a CEO
of a company?
YAEL KAROV: I'm a very technical
CEO, so I really
work on the technological
problems and the algorithms
and hands-on.
I'm also the Chief Scientific
Officer of the company.
So I'm really working almost on
every project and problem
we have together with
the people.
I think I have excellent
people.
And in the company, like in my
own life, I try not to work on
anything operative or technical,
legal, finance, all
that, or even the very technical
aspects of business
development, but to do devote
significant time to product
and technology.
DANA GABEL: Michal, do you want
to ask the last question?
MICHAL SEGALOV: No.
[INAUDIBLE]
DANA GABEL: We're good?
OK.
YAEL KAROV: Thank you.
DANA GABEL: So Yael,
thank you very much
for joining us today.
It was interesting
and inspiring.
Thank you again for joining
us for the second "Israeli
Techmakers." And we're going
to have a few more coming.
We hope to--
MICHAL SEGALOV: Stay tuned.
YAEL KAROV: And thanks for the
opportunity for this interview.
DANA GABEL: Thank you.
MICHAL SEGALOV: Thank you.
Bye.
YAEL KAROV: Bye.